Oh welcome to another episode of what's
in the box I'm BJ and I'm his best
friend Bear and bears got a knife man
just like every good monkey on the road
he's got a knife it's gonna take that
knife he's gonna stab a vagrant on the
side of the road and we're gonna pull
out surprises I think that's what BJ and
the bear was about every week all right
ready okay my sight bogies on the bus
turn to torture look at that dude in
honor of the new Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles movie
we're graph
kraang is in the house ladies and
gentlemen bebop as is Rocksteady finally
they did the right thing with this
franchise this on the other hand is
massive history of the Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtle oh this is [ __ ] badass
comic book 84 hold on let's put this out
this is cool this is every turtle
they've ever made represented by a
figure including the Eastman and Laird
drawings man like what started the
black-and-white original indie comic
that kicked off this whole craze
all the drawings are on the back too
isn't knots dude like at one point this
was an ashcan comic these dudes were
just big fans of daredevil so they kind
of wrote this this comic book and a teed
off on daredevil but their superpowers
come from the sewer where a radioactive
isotope that Matt Murdock pushed the guy
out of the way in the truck that's what
made the turtles the turtle it's the
canister the hab use that transformed
that's all okay so what we have here is
the history of Leonardo man basically
every incarnation of Leonardo is
represented here this is the Eastman and
Laird black and white version but it's
not black and white they should have
done in black and white that would be
cool very nice but whatever I bet you
this looks nice um this next one here is
the cartoon that's what made them super
famous ever all the kids know them from
the cartoon which led in turn to the
movies this one looks like the movie
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtle this one is
called Ninja Turtles the next mutation
he's got like a bubble side like a
scissor more than a sword then you got
the Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles which
was another TV show animated as well
2005 this is Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles fast forward it was called it's
a futuristic take on the heroic mutants
in the storyline Cody Jones the
great-grandson of April and Casey Jones
brings the turtles and splinter to the
Year 2105 that's what was going on in
this one Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
this was the TV show right here that's
been popular right before the launch of
the movie in 24
team these Michael Bay's Leonardo right
there
we're ninjas mutants well technically
work Turtles
oh and with teenagers if you were
Turtles fan which I'm not I respect them
but I was never like a big tourist guy
love the black and white ashcan edition
I did enjoy the movies but I've not been
this guy if I was though I would be like
I'd be popping a turtle head out of my
shell right yeah as this is glorious
this is beautiful man who the [ __ ]
doesn't want this if you remotely like
the turtles the only problem is you
can't take them off their stand this is
more about presentational this is the
kind of thing you put in your rooms that
we bring somebody in you're like this is
who I am and they're like well I'm out
of here this is the only version it
shows that look at that this drawings
babalu yeah and she looked a mask is
around his head it's more of a bandana
than just uh yes
see I like no pupils when they put
pupils on these fools it looks like it's
a [ __ ] cartoon but when they're doing
this [ __ ] you're like yeah this could
happen yeah you know what I'm saying
this could happen this can't happen
this [ __ ] being all happy and
[ __ ] oh yeah that really shouldn't
happen but did
this is bebop and rocksteady Classic
Collection originally released in 1988
1988 when I graduated high school
alright population all right if they're
doing it in the classic style how about
they classically don't [ __ ] tie the
figures into plastic but they didn't do
that in the eighties I'll tell you that
much
let's see how old-school it is nope of
course look at the [ __ ] brownies
not even a man different it's this
[ __ ] her medical seal but it wasn't
it's not the wire isn't it no it's like
anybody can break this alright the
weapon ah all right man I'm able to bust
this here look at this you put this
sewer cap slash shield whoa hey dough
you got away from me look what I'm gonna
put the knife in there instead how about
that he doesn't need a she oh these
I know dude this kid is tough enough do
you know their origins I do not they
start out as humans and then they get
turned into these they never did these
in the movies from what I recall what do
you made you just give us another shot
pal bebop and Rocksteady and Krang are
in the brand-new bring you back to
mohawk good for you Oh y'all got jokes
huh
those Casey Jones April O'Neil comes
back but Casey Jones is in it as well
okay
did I mention Casey Jones yeah and you
know who plays Casey Jones - you're my
Escoto I thought your man does it who's
my man Jason Mewes he's your man he's
your man bro oh my god nobody does the
fire pole thing that's you dude you're
like he's so in shape he don't even need
to we were sure to fight crime yeah
are you guys like a thing this is the og
deep cuts right there kids Krang oh my
god there's a finger called Monte mooks
look at that oh I wanted this is Krang
from back in the day man I don't know if
it's from 1988 but this is an old figure
old-school I am an absolute master you
will do my bidding wacky weapons dude oh
that's makes a figure valuable right
then and there let's see how much we'll
get for a packaged Krang Oh
take a guess this is 1989 okay so three
clerks man this is back to summer of 89
take it back to summer 89 June 23rd
Batman
Tim Burton's Batman is in theaters okay
and in Toy Stores is this Krang figure
which you probably pay less than ten
bucks for what would you pay for it now
good all it's understand you see I'm
thinking with the Turtles movies coming
out and such I'm thinking maybe 75 bucks
50 not too high but you're in the
neighborhood I could go off with the
movie coming out but he's not in the
title but like he's in the trailers
didn't seem so tough
do we open it then and that instead
would say no way sure what are we gonna
do just hold on just look at it and feel
it bro maybe we could finance Mallrats -
oh yeah well I say we open it the point
of the show is what's in the box
but not what's in the packaging just
what's in the box
I've been outwitted by him what a maroon
I am hey there's one more box coming man
let's stop it until it's open with us
yes Rafael's I set limited-edition prop
replicas damn whoa that's nice it looks
like a sword break a manhole cover
pretty handy I know I just I lift it out
of the box - I'm saying look at the hole
look what it says dude power unity
spirit pizza
whoa oh my god I got you know like Oh
[ __ ] is that how you like this
remember when we had that toy with your
name Elektra yeah she's this how she
holds it son
so it's like she but how do you spin and
she can't really stab anyone with the
[ __ ] hurts of all this oh yeah or you
could do this pollutant oh my goodness -
it gets inserted up your rectum here
this is the creepiest part man this is
like that part of seven where they open
the box go to Paltrow's heads instead
it's this guy's hey you know what they
do to the dirt holes are I know he's
like you better [ __ ] send us money or
else we're gonna send you back home
Jesse wait careful cuz we have to
unscrew this I think to put it in the
hand yeah be careful it might explode
okay it pops off it's magnets so you put
this down first then you put that hand
there oh sure just matter
maybe no I think you go the other way I
know but I think it there Fister
opposite that's what they're supposed to
do when you [ __ ] cross sighs you like
this son okay oh yeah don't you know
anything I know that I've never had to
it once
oh it's a magnet well no that never had
two sides at once man aside that oh I
think we're supposed to put something
now it says like Turtles original oh yes
ah we almost lost the ultimate coin it
is the Raphael site 383 out of 1000
coins see the knowledge this is pretty
sweet man in terms of being of Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtle fan you can't do
[ __ ] better than this look we can do
better than this now
Bunga D yes friends the new turbo makes
french fries very different
whoops come on that's classic right
there dude you are the turtles the
spirit of the turtles lives on in you
man take the pizza slice off how much
would you pay for that okay made by
factory entertainment man beautiful
piece clearly inspired by more cartoony
turtles than the ones in the movie you
think right but real of heavy and
realistic sighs here I would say good
399 299 so you're not even paying as
much as you thought you would man only a
hundred of them have been produced which
means 99 of them are never gonna get
sold cuz I don't know who the [ __ ] is
gonna buy that you got to be a massive
raphael fan and most people don't care
for Raphael let's be honest you act like
a jerk sometimes you know that well well
maybe I'll just take my attitude and why
don't you I will let me tell you
something you could take these sides
spigen grind these down the points and
you have real size so you get a statue
then you can also have real good point
for $2.99 you could take a kid's toy and
turn it into a lethal weapon but you
could probably buy a pair of size for
about a hundred bucks you can also drill
a hole in the arms the hands wrists and
you can put your own wrists hands and
then you give like oh I bet turtle
you can also each hand has a hole in it
as we saw oho so if you really wanted to
get freaky okay Jeff oh yeah how could I
not force it in there I'd be like you do
it Raphael let's do it for sensei that's
pretty damn impressive man what about
the turtles here what about the history
of Leonardo eight pack eight different
figures and Leonardo represented all
throughout history in it what would you
be willing to pay for this I would say
this is another art piece innocence so I
would say this is my original a Oh
Toys R Us exclusive Oh 1999
you're out of your [ __ ] mind there's
eight figures here oh you're right that
would be two dollars a figure all right
you where'd you [ __ ] steam in from the
70s no okay let me think I mean give you
a little piece of information because
there was one missing there's a 2007
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles CG movie
that I did a voice in for one Scene and
it says the 2007 animated movie Leonardo
was not produced because the Chinese
factory destroyed the sculpts originally
used to make it okay man what do you
think how much $49.99 keep going 75 99
close to a Hondo 9999 I know my figures
are there 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 so 8 into a
hundred bucks is what it goes in 128 I
didn't know we'd be doing math Cowabunga
kids that is a showing right there man
that's what we found this week in the
box you want to see is pull more things
out of the box things you'd like to see
us pull out if you like I'm [ __ ]
tired of the Turtles
I'd rather see you pull dead things out
about you got to tell somebody that
we're not mind reader's man tell the
screen junkies go to Twitter or the
Facebook page or write them at this
address below and tell them what you
want to see us pull out of things
they'll tell us we'll do it man will do
anything that you ask us to with our
mouths that's all the time we got this
week for what's in the box kids I'm
Kevin Smith Jesse muse and what's in the
box has been this tu r t le power the
best they don't fight each other
hi friend let's go make log wall be in
the show they don't make love either
[Music]